as attorneys prepare for the trial of
jeffrey epstein's close associate and
former girlfriend
glenn maxwell the reporter who brought
the case to national attention
is revealing details of her
groundbreaking investigation
miami herald investigative reporter
julie k brown
is out with a new book called perversion
of justice the jeffrey epstein story
it takes readers through her more than
two-year investigation
into epstein's alleged underage sex
trafficking scheme
we'll talk with her first on cbs this
morning in just a moment
but first mola lenghi shows us how the
impact of brown's reporting
is still being felt today the paper's
bombshell report
it is disturbing this is some journalism
it's the story that ignited a firestorm
in 2018 miami herald reporter julie k
brown published the series
perversion of justice it detailed a
secret plea deal over sexual abuse
allegations
jeffrey epstein struck with federal
prosecutors in south florida
nearly a decade earlier then u.s
attorney alex acosta negotiated the plea
deal with epstein's attorneys that
required the former investment banker
to register as a sex offender and serve
13 months in a florida county jail
he could have faced life in prison he
just laid
down in his towel brown's series
chronicled the suffering of just
some of the dozens of alleged victims
lured into what prosecutors call
epstein's sex trafficking scheme he
needs to be behind bars he needs to be
behind bars for the rest of his life
brown's reports and interviews with
victims had a big impact
prompting a new investigation
billionaire businessman
jeffrey epstein was arrested on federal
charges related to sex
trafficking labor secretary alex acosta
says he will
now resign because of the controversy
surrounding the plea deal he worked out
with jeffrey epstein
i'm not going into any aspects of how
our investigation
originated i will say that we were
assisted from
some excellent investigative journalism
after just over a month in prison
authorities say jeffrey epstein
died by suicide in his manhattan jail
cell for all of the epstein victims it's
going to take a long time
to really get their minds around this
any co-conspirators
should not rest easy one of those
alleged co-conspirators is epstein's
close friend and associate glenn maxwell
she's being held in brooklyn's
metropolitan detention center accused of
recruiting and helping the disgraced
financier
sexually abuse underage girls charges
she denies
maxwell faces trial in november giving
epstein's alleged victims another chance
for their day in court it would have
been great to look at him in court and
say
you know you hurt me you took away my
innocence you took away my youth
i'm really hoping we get to do this with
guilin
julie k brown joins us now for an
interview you'll see first on cbs this
morning julie good morning
congratulations on the book
i want to ask you first about that 2008
plea deal
which gave immunity to any potential
accomplices
of jeffrey epstein it did not name gulen
maxwell
but she is now contending in court the
charges should be dropped
because of that what do you make of that
well you know he she was an integral
part
of his life whether you want to say he
she
committed any crimes or not she was his
right-hand person
for a very long time during when we know
that these crimes happened
so it's going to be hard i think for
them to for them to convince
anyone that she wasn't involved and
the plea deal itself as you mentioned
didn't
didn't name her but she's going to you
know the wording of the plea deal said
uh co-conspirators named and unnamed
which is something that
i've talked to legal experts about and
they say this is not done
why would you do that you usually make a
plea bargain like this when you have
when the defendant has something of
value to offer prosecutors and we
we have found no evidence that he gave
anything to prosecutors in return
some documents were released last week
but we still don't have
base the basic documents of the fbi case
do we no
no there's you know one of the
underlying uh pieces of this story is
how much
is still secret uh how many things are
still
sealed how many things are redacted how
much information
even involving his death there is so
much we don't know
and as long as we don't have these kinds
of
information we're going there's always
going to be conspiracy theories number
one and number two
i mean it's way really to keep people
silent because they're afraid
and it's it's a mechanism to hide the
truth i think
you know it's interesting you write that
a lot of big names were friendly with
epstein but you also say
that they tell you that they knew
nothing about his illegal contact
with women um a lot of people will find
that hard to believe
what is your reporting uncovered well
you know epstein
had a whole ecosystem of people he did
not do this crime
in isolation there were a lot of people
around him during this time whether it
was through social circles
or were in his inner circle so to speak
uh i think that there are a lot of
questions about these people who
um you know they wrote on his plane for
example
um i you know everyone
from the butler who answered the door to
the you know the schedulers and
ultimately
to the people who were involved it's
it's such a wide
web and i think that it needs to be
examined a little closer
what is the message you talk about this
wide web
the plea deal all of this what is the
message to other
victims not even just in the epstein
case alleged victims
about the power structure that's set up
to protect somebody who has money and
who has the resources like this
well what it says is that vulnerable
people are going to continue to be
reluctant to come forward and other
people surrounding
those like epstein are also as long as
they are silent
as long as everybody keeps their mouth
shut then it it
does more to bury the truth and it also
makes it more uh unlikely that other
victims are going to come forward
does it give his victims any chance of
of closure when there
there is this out there still that there
is this larger issue looming
well his victims are still angry they're
very angry
uh they really haven't had their their
justice
you know they feel like he escaped by
his own by his own death
he did and even though maxwell
is is being has been charged they
and i have information my reporting
shows that there were other
powerful people that were involved in
this just the two of them did not do
this
and you know i we hope that authorities
are examining every
tie that epstein had and put together
exactly how he
managed to do this for so long i mean it
was a long time you have julie you have
a chapter in your book title jeffrey
epstein didn't kill himself
now now i know some of the lawyers for
some of the victims who believe he did
kill himself what evidence do you have
that he didn't
well let's put it this way i i think
that there's
again um too much much has been hidden
you know the cameras weren't working the
guards were
asleep there are a lot of people you
know his
cell mate was taken out the night before
i mean
and he shouldn't have been left alone he
was just released from suicide watch
so as long as they keep the the
investigation itself secret as long as
they do not release the details i think
there's going to be always a question
about this and and by the way he was a
kind of man who didn't do anything alone
i mean he had butler's to practically
tie his shoelaces
the idea that he could have the
wherewithal to
break three bones in his neck by himself
is just i think incredulous to me
before we go in 30 seconds i mean one of
the things that i'm fascinated by
the victims who've come forward and
spoken to you could this have happened
without the metoo movement
yeah i think it could have um you know i
was working on this before the
metoo movement i i think that it helped
um that that this happened in the middle
of my investigation
but they really didn't feel the victims
in this case didn't feel
like they were uh like me to the metoo
movement remember
was about a lot of famous people that
came forward with
weinstein so different situations
certainly right these young girls as you
pointed out that
were the ones no one was going to listen
to right first place julie it's a
fascinating book
and a story that people continue to
follow thank you thanks for having me
and don't forget that perversion of
justice is on sale
now